[Música]
un lanzador un receptor y una pelota
cuando el bateador logra golpear la
pelota corre para lograr una carrera
recorriendo las bases para volver a su
punto de partida home y marcar un punto
la dificultad la pelota es pequeña y
alcanza velocidades de 150 kilómetros
por hora
le dice que el béisbol es un deporte 70
por ciento mental y 30 por ciento físico
porque es un deporte en el que se falla
mucho sobre todo cuando se es bateador
el bateador es eliminado si falla tres
veces
aun los buenos bateadores terminan
siendo eliminados dos de cada tres veces
así tienen que vivir a lo largo del año
con una sensación de frustración porque
infortunadamente nunca se ha logrado el
100% en estos olímpicos los hombres
competirán en facebook y las mujeres en
software esto a pesar de que ambos
deportes son mixtos y que las
diferencias son mínimos el campo es más
pequeño porque la pelota es más pesada
entonces llega menos lejos y la
lanzadora envía la pelota por debajo y
no para arriba esto se debe a que hace
muchos años los beisbolistas necesitaban
entrenarse durante el invierno en
gimnasios entonces se adaptaron a las
dimensiones que eran más pequeñas surge
en inglaterra pero el béisbol se
estructuró y organizó en eeuu atravesó
las fronteras se popularizó en el caribe
y se convirtió en el deporte nacional de
japón en europa no ha logrado afianzarse
fue deporte olímpico hasta 2008 y en
tokio está de regreso
al estar en europa uno sabe que hay
pocas oportunidades de quedar pero
cuando se está en eeuu en la parte
norteamericana y la parte asiática sabe
que no habrá problema que no hay de qué
preocuparse porque nos volverán a
incluir en el programa los ires y
venires del béisbol continúan no estará
en el programa de parís 2024 pero es
para regresar para 2028 en los ángeles